MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
In this section we want to look
at how we can theoretically
describe masses of neutrinos.
There is not just
one way to do this
and the judge is still out
there which one is actually
realized in nature, or perhaps
both are realized in nature.
So mass terms can be
constructed by introducing
so-called sterile neutrinos.
The first way, and it's
shown here in the Lagrangian,
is very familiar
to you where you
have a left-handed
component of a particle
coupling via the Higgs boson
to a right-handed component.
Now, if we now have a
right-handed component
or right-handed neutrino,
that neutrino does not
interact with the
weak interaction
and doesn't interact with any
other interaction we know.
Hence, this neutrino,
this right-handed particle
is a sterile neutrino.
It's not interacting in
any of known ways other
than with the Higgs field with
the rest of the standard model.
The second part, the second way
the mechanism is using Majorana
particles, particles which
are their own antiparticles,
and we'll look in how
this is being implemented.
So again, the first,
the Dirac term
is generated after
electroweak symmetry breaking
from Yukawa interactions.
We have seen the very same
thing for our charged leptons.
What we see here is that the
lepton number is conserved.
Before and after
the interaction we
have the same number of leptons,
but the lepton flavor is not
conserved in this interaction.
We can rewrite this.
We identify the sterile neutrino
as the right-handed component
of the spinor.
I mentioned this
already, and we basically
couple the
weak-doublet components
as you would just
expect that to appear.
The second term, the
Majorana mass term,
is interesting as we
introduce another singlet
into the standard model.
So this then can
appear as a bare mass
term with some consequences.
So here what we
are trying to do is
we are involved two neutrinos,
right-handed fields.
Those break the lepton number.
So if those neutrinos
are realized in nature,
we have to observe lepton--
we should observe lepton
number-violating processes.
And so the search for the
specific kind of neutrino
is through searching for lepton
number-violating processes.
So we can rewrite this
part of the Lagrangian,
this part of the math term
here using this matrix.
Let's see how this unfolds.
If the math term now is
much, much larger, or larger
than the electroweak
scale, you can
try to diagonalize
the master and it
leads to three neutrinos,
three light neutrinos,
three light neutrinos
you would expect,
and one potentially--
one potential, or maybe
multiple potential
heavy neutrinos.
If you then rewrite
the math term
you find for the light
ones, the term which goes
is 1 over the scale of
this [? known ?] neutrino.
That is a nice motivation
for this kind of physics
as it automatically reduces
the amount of the neutrino
as we observe the math is
to be very small in nature.
And then the mass of
the heavy neutrino
is proportional to the mass.
This mechanism is called see-saw
because it automatically moves
the scales of those
two neutrinos,
the heavy ones and the light one
apart so you happen to observe
the heavy one, maybe because
they're very, very heavy,
and the light ones have light
mass because of this mechanism
of being proportional to
1 over the mass scale--
the mass eigenstate
of those neutrinos.
However, if the mass scale of
those eigenvalues is much--
not higher than the
electroweak scale,
the low energy spectrum contains
these additional light states.
So you have not just the
three light neutrinos but you
have additional light scales--
states which mix with these
three light neutrinos.
And that is kind of
an interesting area
to look for these particles
as they would lead
to small deviations in
observed electroweak
efficient properties,
and they might
yield to some interesting
decays in nuclear physics,
and we'll come to
those specifics later.
We have seen in this
lecture two different ways
to generate masses.
One's to recover
interactions, same
as the interaction with
the Higgs field, and one,
we have the see-saw mechanism
introducing Majorana neutrinos.